le mulassier est une race issue du
marais poitevin et qui connaît une
augmentation croissante par le caractère
séduisant de ces sujets
on
à des lieues de l'agitation citadine
comme un peu préservé par le temps
certains éleveurs entretiennent avec un
amour sans limites
la passion de leurs chevaux la nostalgie
nous prend au plus profond de nous en
voyant cette gerbe hier cahoter sur le
chemin des champs sous l'impulsion du
cheval de tête le chevillard et le
timonier entraîne leur cargaison au
rythme du claquement des sabots et des
grincements de roue ces mots résonnent
d'un sont magiques et évoque notre
enfance où le progrès n'avait pas tous
dépassés dans son rythme destructeur ces
images d'autrefois nous rappelle combien
la vie était simple et si parfois le
travail était très dur elle évoque des
jours de bonheur qu'il faisait bon vivre
au quotidien
encore utilisés pour leurs qualités
écologiques les chevaux de trait
participe souvent aux travaux des champs
tels que les fenaisons comme si le temps
n'avait pas de prise sur lui ce couple
de percherons obéi à des ordres vieux de
plus d'un siècle
heureusement ils tirent la faucheuse
sans jamais marquer de l'impatience me
d'hésitation véritable tabernacle d'une
culture ancestrale l'air détaché qu'ils
arborent force l'admiration
ils n'ont pas évolué et sont restés les
mêmes ils n'ont pas été transformés par
le luxe et l'envié qui ont si souvent
divisé notre société ces dernières
années les poussé l'homme à bien des
excès
via
trouver ces authentiques dresseur de
chevaux n'est pas chose facile pour le
touriste mais lorsque l'on a le bonheur
d'en découvrir au détour d'une route de
campagne
il faut savoir prendre le temps de
l'observer prendre le temps d'observer
ces gestes simples accompli avec la
certitude de celui qui a du métier
nous en avons rencontré quelques-uns par
la magie de ré de la lumière d'un soir
nous avons retrouvé avec délice le calme
avec lequel ils dressent leurs chevaux
ces gens qui ont décidé de prendre le
temps de vivre ne connaissent que
l'amour de leurs bêtes et l'attraction
de communiquer avec elle
allez voir simplement attelé on prend
une fantastique leçon de modestie chez
eux
le stress n'existe pas le temps et leurs
alliés et puis si on nous y retrouver
nos racines
mariée au bras
q où en arié et recule à laillé recul
variés
trop peu nombreux sont les agriculteurs
qui prennent le temps de verser la pâte
sûrs de leurs vaches avec des chevaux et
de simples outils comme le fait devant
nous monsieur andré bach pourtant au
temps où l'écologie doit être prise en
compte
rien n'est plus simple pour les herbages
que de se voir refouler par quelques
paires de sabots
à
il est très difficile de trouver des
agriculteurs qui laboure avec des
chevaux rares sont ceux qui ont su
conserver le savoir et surtout qu'ils
savent dresser des chevaux à ce labeur
au début du dressage
la principale difficulté est d'unir les
efforts des deux chevaux dans une ré
parfaitement droites en ayant pour seul
repère que le sillon précédent comme
dans toutes les disciplines équestres
calme et patience sont de mise
on commence par leur fait retirer une
averse
puis avec d'infinies précautions on les
appelle à la charrue
ça
la force que leur impose la résistance
du soc brise souvent leur union et
chacun tire dans son sens un peu dans le
désordre
le dresseur est souvent amené à faire
tirer à ses élèves une lourde charge sur
un curieux chars doté de patin de bois
afin d'apprendre aux jeunes à se placer
dans le collier et à tirer ensemble
d'une seule force
généralement doux et les chevaux
apprennent très vite et un travail plus
productif peut commencer
parmi les métiers ayant leurs origines
au plus profond des temps le maréchal
ferrant n'est pas le dernier travaille
dur et pénible
il est toujours indispensable car chez
les paysans comme chez les cavaliers
huppé pas de pied pas de cheval le
ferrand faire les bêtes sur un travail
sorte de cadre en bois sur lequel est
attaché le cheval et qui le soutient
pour inviter au maréchal d'accumuler
trop de fatigue après avoir paré le pied
c'est à dire enlever la corne poussé en
excès il tourne le faire en d'autres
mots lui donne la forme et la taille du
sabot le faire est appliquée à chaud sur
la corne afin de s'adapter parfaitement
à celle ci avant d'y être fixé
solidement à l'aide de clous
oh
à
il est concours de modèles et allures
sont des manifestations très apprécié
des éleveurs
c'est pour eux l'occasion de montrer des
produits dont ils sont fiers et de
participer au maintien de leur race
favorite
en
encore
oh
où
non
un jury de spécialistes apprécient et
notent chaque modèle en fonction des
critères très stricts
com
des concours d'attelage sont
régulièrement organisées au cours de ces
fêtes régionales au caractère
extrêmement convivial un parcours de
maniabilité permet aux spectateurs
d'apprécier la finesse des meneurs dans
la conduite de l'attelage tandis qu'un
parcours de marathon confronte les
équipages à des obstacles impressionnant
je
dans les épreuves marathon au cours
desquelles maniabilité et puissances
doivent être conjuguées les chevaux
donne pleinement la mesure de leur
courage et de leur bonne volonté
m
à
parmi toutes les épreuves
le concours de traction attire un public
nombreux des charges considérables sont
entraînés sur plusieurs dizaines de
mètres par des chevaux surpuissant il
n'est pas rare de voir emploi total
dépasse et 1200 kg on peut aussi voir
des chevaux à l'apparence très robuste
se faire battre par des modèles plus
légers
car dans ce type d'épreuve la victoire
est souvent dans le savoir-faire du
meneur
comparable aux 24 heures du mans la
route du poisson retrace les aventures
des mareyeurs du siècle dernier
les attelages se succèdent sur des
étapes de 20 à 30 kilomètres de
boulogne-sur-mer à paris deux jours
durant
les relayeurs affronte la nuit des
intempéries ou le manque de sommeil pour
offrir un spectacle éblouissant aux
curieux qui se retrouvent sur la place
des villes étapes pour les encourager
ouais
et
des expériences intéressantes ont lieu
dans quelques collectivités locales
comme dans la ville de rambouillet où
les cantonniers dispose d'un attelage de
magnifiques boulonnais tous les matins
les travaux de cantonnage sont effectués
dans la ville pour le plus grand plaisir
des habitants
ces expériences sont malheureusement peu
suivi car bien sûr elles ne sont pas
assez rentables malgré la possibilité
qu'elle offre de faire visiter les sites
touristiques dans des conditions plus
distrayant que dans un autobus
fumant et bruyant
ah que la cptaq est la taupe d'epr aux
le débardage du bois est l'une des
activités les plus productives de
travail pour les chevaux de trait nous
avons suivi jean-françois cot oran dans
une de ces journées
le spectacle est partout victoire label
ardennaise est tout simplement fabuleuse
avec un courage rarement vu elle
accomplit sa tâche quelle que soient les
difficultés qui s'offrent à ses membres
trapu avec force et caractère
elle tire plus de huit heures par jour
c'est loupé de billes de bois dans un
terrain parfois ingrat son maître et son
complice qui se connaissent si bien
et elle connaît si bien son métier que
tout paraît facile
il ne lui donne pas d'ordre ils se
parlent et se comprennent et les
regarder travailler est une leçon
d'amour toi
monsieur gilbert fournier du haras des
bréviaires nous présente les efforts
entrepris par les haras nationaux pour
sauvegarder ses reins ce magnifique
alors le rôle des rats nationaux et donc
depuis leur création qui remonte à ses
165 crée donc par décision de colbert a
évolué bien entendu au fil des temps au
jour d'aujourd'hui il est articulé
autour de trois pôles un pôle élevage un
pôle développement d'équitation et un
pôle suivi des courses alors sur le pôle
élevage rapidement consiste
essentiellement à mettre à disposition
des éleveurs des étalons appelé talents
nationaux de seulement parce qu'ils sont
propriété de l'état qui sont mis donc à
disposition des éleveurs qui soit mettre
des juments à leur production et qui
permet donc par ce biais là donc de
proposer à ces mêmes éleveurs des
étalons de
dont on connaît la valeur au niveau
reproduction à des prix qui sont
relativement abordables
les chevaux de trait en tant que race
sont quand même d'assez longs étaient
fortement donc dès l'apparition du de la
motorisation on a cherché depuis un
certain nombre de missions d'orientation
qui pourraient être donnés donc à 7 à ce
volet de production du cheval en
particulier certain temps vers la
production de viande
activité orientation toujours existante
mais moins moins évidente pour des tas
de pour différentes raisons
ce qui fait que l'on se porte plus
maintenant sur d'autres orientations qui
permettrait de relancer un peu hauts du
mois de maintenir l'activité donc la
production de choses près
ces différentes orientations fond le
débardage en forêt qui reste quand même
petite activité mais néanmoins
d'activité réelle l'entretien des
espaces boisés surtout alors dans notre
région ile-de-france des espaces boire
basée en zone périurbaine donc qui
demande quand même donc une certaine
heure qui répondent à une certaine
qualité de l'environnement et le chant
s'intègre très bien dans ses activités
mieux comme moteur d'autres activités
attelage de loisirs qui se développe
aussi beaucoup le cheval dans la ville
aussi tout près d'ici dans la ville de
rambouillet de trois chevaux
actuellement trois chevaux de trait qui
travaille sur la voirie entretien divers
on trouve aussi on l'a fortement incitée
encouragés par les haras nationaux dans
le cadre de l'opération un cheval de
trait par centre équestre
on essaie de faire en sorte qu'on trouve
à cheval de trait dans chaque centre
équestre
le pari n'est pas gagné mais enfin il ya
quand même des des avancées
significatives qui sont réelles et
connus ou ce cheval de trait en fait
dans le sens doute dans le cas du centre
équestre pu avoir un certain nombre de
raisons d'être soi l'entretien du manège
c'est la planche et le manège soient
aidés donc aux chars wade du fumier soit
participer carrément dans la vie des
reprises d'équitation à travers faire un
peu de voltige faire différentes choses
et puis on se rend compte que dans
chaque centre équestre où il ya déjà un
cheval de trait le cheval de trait vient
très vite la mascotte du centre un peu
le chouchou des enfants et des plus
grands cette volonté d'ouverture pas
vise à faire connaître ce que font les
haras nationaux
ce qu'est le cheval donc montrer donc
qu'ensemble de techniques montrent ainsi
nombre de traditions et d'encadrer cette
ouverture donc on nous accueillons
certain nombre de visiteurs cette
vitrine aussi avait tout à fait sa place
dire que donc on va relancer la
production et retrouver des chiffres
d'entendre non par contre ça peut aider
toutes ces utilisations donc qu'ils
peuvent être remises un petit peu au
goût du jour
associé à des utilisations qui n'était
pas du tout le cas avant dans les
centres équestres notamment peuvent
aider à maintenir
envie en fait ces deux phrases qui
représente qu il faut le reconnaître le
patrimoine patrimoine génétique national
important qui serait vraiment dommage de
laisser disparaître
et là je crois qu'on contribue à
maintenir on développera pas outre
mesure
enfin si je crois que si le pari que
nous avons fait de maintenir en vie
et un nombre donc au dessus d'un seuil
critique en dessous duquel une pile
aucune race ne peut vivre on à la
consanguinité autres en dessous de ce
seuil la cie ont réussi à maintenir des
neuf races on pourra dire qu'on a gagné
notre pari je crois que ce sera déjà pas
mal
pour les innombrables services qu'ils
ont rendus à l'homme pour avoir toujours
été fidèle à ses côtés même dans les
moments difficiles et pour être prêt à
affronter le troisième millénaire avec
un courage plus gros que ce film ne
saurait l'exprimer il faut tout faire
pour que les chevaux de trait conservent
leur place dans notre société
ils sont les garants de nos racines
profondes de notre culture paysanne tant
de souvenirs sont attachés à eux que
tout doit être fait pour qu'il vive dans
un bonheur que nous leur devons bien